en el vídeo pasado calculamos un
intervalo de confianza de 95% para la
diferencia de pérdida de peso promedio
entre tomar la dieta baja en grasas y
estar en el grupo control lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es una comparación
de hipótesis para ver si pues pues
realmente a partir de esta información
podemos inferir que la dieta baja en
grasas realmente funciona para esto
necesitamos una hipótesis nula y una
hipótesis alternativa nuestra hipótesis
nula va a ser las siguientes la
hipótesis no la va a ser que hay sabes
que la dieta baja en grasas no funciona
para nada y lo que esto quiere decir en
términos de medias es que la media la
media poblacional del grupo bajo en
grasa menos la media poblacional del
grupo control es igual a cero ahora esto
de aquí es exactamente lo mismo esto es
un enunciado equivalente a decir que la
media de x1 barra es decir la media
muestral de nuestro grupo bajo en grasa
menos la media de la distribución
muestral de nuestro grupo control es
igual a cero esto de aquí pues ya vimos
muchas veces porque es verdad
la media de la distribución muestral es
igual a la media poblacional entonces
este es igual a este este es igual a
este y por eso la equivalencia que
escribí otra forma de escribirlo es pues
a través de la distribución de la
diferencia de las medias muestrales es
decir podemos escribir mu de x1 menos x2
barra y que estoy aquí sea igual a 0
porque porque esta expresión está que
estoy marcando es lo mismo que esta
expresión de acá esto fue lo que vimos
en el vídeo pasado entonces eso de ahí
sería la hipótesis nula y la hipótesis
alternativa sería lo siguiente la
hipótesis alternativa la voy a escribir
por acá h 1 sería que la dieta baja en
grasas tiene algún efecto entonces como
lo escribiría déjame escribirlo de la
siguiente forma que me dé sabes que en
vez de decir que hace algo vamos a decir
que es mejor entonces que tenemos más
pérdida de peso
eso lo escribiríamos como que mundo la
media poblacional del grupo 1 - mudos la
media poblacional del grupo 2 es mayor
que 0 perdemos más peso con la dieta que
es sin la dieta
estoy aquí es una distribución de una
cola y otra forma de escribirlo es que
mucho de la diferencia de las
distribuciones x1 y x2 con barras es
mayor que es 0 muy bien estoy aquí son
enunciados equivalentes esto es lo mismo
que esto que es lo mismo que esto de acá
que es lo que escribí por acá nada raro
ahora para realmente hacer cualquier
tipo de comparación de hipótesis debemos
de decidir un nivel de significancia es
decir a ver cómo funciona esto lo que
vamos a hacer es asumir que la hipótesis
nula es correcta luego bajo esta
suposición de que la hipótesis nula es
correcta vamos a calcular la
probabilidad de obtener esta muestra de
obtener este valor de aquí
y esa probabilidad de obtener ese valor
es menor que cierto umbral lo que vamos
a hacer es rechazar la hipótesis nula y
vamos a favorecer la hipótesis
alternativa ahora esa probabilidad el
límite ese umbral se conoce como nivel
de significancia y se denota como alfa
aquí en este ejemplo vamos a poner que
alfa es igual a 95% otra forma de pensar
lo que queremos que asumiendo que la
hipótesis nula es correcta queremos ver
si hay más de 5 por ciento de
probabilidad de obtener este resultado
por lo que es lo mismo no más de un 5%
de probabilidad de rechazar la hipótesis
nula incorrectamente va muy bien
entonces si hay una probabilidad menor
al 5% de obtener este valor una
probabilidad menor al 5% vamos a
rechazar la hipótesis nula
y lo que vamos a hacer bueno claro
suponiendo la hipótesis nula entonces
vamos a rechazar la hipótesis nula y
vamos a irnos por la hipótesis
alternativa baja entonces vamos a ver
cómo están las cosas estamos suponiendo
la hipótesis nula la hipótesis nula nos
diría que la diferencia de las medias
que es lo mismo que la media de las
diferencias muy de x1 menos x2 es igual
a cero
ahora en esta situación cuál sería
nuestra región crítica cuál tendría que
ser el valor de acá cual tendrá que ser
el valor crítico de z voy a ponerlo por
acá o el z score no sabes que no debería
decir el valor crítico de feta porque
esto de aquí no es una distribución de
estándar una distribución normal una
distribución normal estándar entonces
sería simplemente un valor crítico un
valor crítico en un valor crítico de
zeta
lo más difícil aquí en estadística es
pues tenerlas las definiciones correctas
verdad pero va entonces hay un valor
crítico para el cual obtener una muestra
arriba de ese valor crítico sólo es del
5%
muy bien entonces tenemos que determinar
cuál es este valor crítico de aquí y si
nuestro valor es mayor o sea c 1.91 le
gana el valor crítico podemos rechazar
la hipótesis nula verdad rechazamos la
hipótesis nula y nos vamos con la
hipótesis alternativa
para determinar ese valor crítico y
ahora hay que acordarnos que aquí no
podemos utilizar el valor z porque todo
aquí no es normal verdad esto de aquí
todavía no está estandarizado entonces
para encontrar este valor crítico
necesitamos pasar toda una distribución
de estándar de este modo lo que tenemos
que hacer es replantear este problema en
una distribución estándar normal
entonces voy a dibujarlo algo así y aquí
voy a poner otra vez la región del 5% y
aquí cuál es el valor crítico z
el valor crítico de z de tal forma que
que de tal forma que arriba de ese valor
simplemente tengamos un 5 por ciento de
probabilidad entonces lo de acá sería
95% teniendo este 95% ya podemos ir a
nuestra tabla y al buscar por 95%
tenemos que buscar x
por punto 95 déjame ver cuál nos queda
más cerquita quizás nos convenga a
pasarnos un poquito este acá es el más
se quita es punto 95 05 pero está bien
está un poquito a la derecha pero es el
valor que más se acerca eso es 1.65 va
entonces el valor crítico z es igual a
1.65 de modo que ahora sí pasando a la
distribución que tenemos esta distancia
de acá va a ser un 1.65 multiplicado por
la desviación estándar de la diferencia
de las medias muestrales ok entonces
simplemente escribe aquí la la
desviación estándar nada raro
cuál es la desviación estándar estoy
aquí ya lo calculamos en el vídeo pasado
lo vamos a volver a calcular aquí la
desviación estándar de la diferencia de
las medias muestral es de x1 barra menos
x2 barra va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada de aquí nuestra fórmula decía
la varianza de la población 1 pero bueno
aquí no tenemos realmente la varianza de
la población 1 lo que hacemos es estimar
lo con la desviación estándar de la
muestra y elevar eso al cuadrado
nos quedaría esto elevado al cuadrado y
tenemos que dividir esto de acá la
varianza o bueno el estimado de la
varianza poblacional entre el tamaño de
la muestra entonces nos quedaría 4.67 al
cuadrado entre 100 y a eso tenemos que
sumarle pues lo mismo con el otro grupo
el mejor estimado de la varianza del
grupo 2 que sería 4.04 elevado al
cuadrado baja la desviación estándar al
cuadrado dividido entre 100 esto de aquí
es igual a y creo que ya luís en el
vídeo pasado y lo dejé en la calculadora
a ver déjame traerla para ver qué pasa
si todavía está ahí 4.67 elevado al
cuadrado entre 100 más 4.04 elevado al
cuadrado dividido en 300 puntos 6-17
entonces este valor de aquí es igual a
cero ahí lo puse muy grande
ese 0.6 17
muy bien esto de aquí es la desviación
estándar y a partir de esta desviación
estándar la distancia que nos interesa
sería 0.6 17 x 1.02 vamos a ver cuánto
es eso entonces vamos a tomar puntos 6
17 y esto de aquí tenemos que
multiplicarlo por 1.65 es 1.018 o bien
vamos a ponerle pues 1.02 va entonces
esta distancia de aquí marcada en rojo
va a ser igual a 1.02 lo que nos dice
esto es que simplemente hay un 5% de
probabilidad de que la diferencia de las
medias claro suponiendo la hipótesis
nula verdad si estamos suponiendo la
hipótesis nula simplemente hay un 5% de
probabilidad de tener una diferencia de
entre estas dos medias de estas dos
medias muestrales que sea mayor a 1.02
verdad simplemente hay un 5% de
probabilidad pero obtuvimos un 1.91 1.91
fue la medida que obtuvimos eso que nos
diría pues quedaría por acá el 1.91 y
pues si cae en la región
de modo que la probabilidad de obtener
un 1.91 asumiendo la hipótesis nula es
menor que 5% va entonces eso de ahí es
justo lo que queríamos verdad es menor
que nuestro nivel de significancia 5 lo
que le escribí mal este alfa no es 95 %
alfa va a ser igual a 5 % creo que si lo
había dicho bien pero lo escribí mal
datos en y que dice pero bueno no quiero
dejarte con la idea incorrecta en nivel
de significancia sería 5% o sea algo
igual a 5% que es la probabilidad que
queremos que caiga fuera entonces la
probabilidad de que de que obtengamos
1.91 suponiendo la hipótesis nula esa
probabilidad de ahí es menor que nuestro
nivel de significancia es menor que 5% y
entonces basados en los criterios que
nos pusimos al principio vamos a
rechazar la hipótesis nula y en vez de
esto vamos a estar a favor de la
hipótesis alternativa es decir que la
dieta baja en grasas si funciona y
pierdes más peso